For centuries we’ve been warned of the dangers
that lurk deep below the ocean’s surface.
Maybe there’s a horrifying colossal squid,
or a Kraken, or an evil villain’s lair.
As it turns out, the reality is far worse.
Hey there polluting population, Jules here
for DNews!
The Mariana Trench is the deepest known part
of the ocean, stretching down roughly 36,000
feet.
You’d imagine that at those depths, the
ocean floor is pristine, almost untouched
by human activity.
Well, I’ve got some bad news for ya.
Turns out, the bottom of the ocean is very,
very polluted.
And that’s not some click-bait hyperbole;
it is more polluted than some of the most
polluted regions on the surface of the globe.
One probe into the Marianas Trench only had
to go about 16,000 feet down to find physical
remnants of actual garbage, not just waste
byproducts.
Beer cans, plastic bags, even an entire, unopened
can of SPAM was found resting along the Trench’s
wall.
And unless it is removed, this trash can stay
down there indefinitely, just piling up.
Plastics, for example, are made up of super-strong
carbon to carbon bonds.
These bonds are not prone to being broken
down by organic organisms; the material hasn’t
existed in nature long enough for there to
have evolved much to break it down.
In 2016 scientists found one type of microbe
that can do it, but only for a specific type
of plastic.
And even if we could solve this physical trash
problem, there lies an even deeper problem.
Literally.
In late 2016, a paper published in the journal
Nature, examined the inhabitants of two of
the deepest oceanic trenches in the world.
Small little crustaceans called amphipods
are the perfect study specimen, as they have
fatty tissue, which stores not just fat but
also any chemicals that are ingested.
And despite these amphipods being located
in two different parts of the world, thousands
of feet below the surface, they were ALL contaminated
by what are called “persistent organic pollutants”
or POPs.
“Persistent” meaning that they don’t
break down in their environment, and are almost
impossible to remove.
These include chemicals that have been banned
from use for decades, at least in the United
States, like polychlorinated biphenyls, which
have been shown to be birth defect and cancer-causing.
Other chemicals like pesticides were present
as well.
The concentration of POPs was SO high that
it was 50 times greater than in one of China’s
most polluted rivers, and was roughly equal
to that of Suruga Bay in Japan, an industrial
waste dumping ground.
So, how did this pollution make it all the
way down there?
Well the researchers suggest that, in the
case of the Mariana Trench, it may have to
do with a little something called the Great
Pacific Garbage Patch.
While there are many areas where trash congregates
in the ocean, the paper refers to a huge floating
clump of garbage in the Northwest Pacific
ocean that floats just near the Mariana’s
Trench, and so plastics and other chemicals
end up sinking to its depths.
There’s another theory that the pollution
found down there is the result of POP chemicals
entering the food chain.
The amphipods that live in these deep waters
are scavengers.
When a larger animal, like a dolphin or a
whale, dies, it slowly sinks to the bottom
of the ocean floor, a phenomenon known as
carrion-falls.
If this carrion lived in polluted waters,
then it could have pollution in its system,
and that pollution would persist in animals
that eat it.
The paper does say that this is unlikely,
however, given that there is consistent contamination
at different depths.
But either of these theories for how the POPs
got so deep would be a huge problem for us
humans.
If these chemicals are so persistent within
the food chain, then they eventually reach
our own food supply, contaminating it with
our own contaminants.
But it isn’t just bad for us, it’s bad
for every living thing.
Ocean pollution saps the amount of oxygen
in the water, which can lead to mass death
of marine life.
Certain chemicals can even create reproductive
issues for animals in the ocean, so even if
they do survive, they can’t do much for
their species.
Society has spent the last few centuries dumping
tons of trash into the ocean, including industrial
waste, radioactive waste, munitions, and sewage.
The EPA says, quote, “Wastes were frequently
dumped in coastal and ocean waters based on
the assumption that marine waters had an unlimited
capacity to mix and disperse wastes.”
But now we’re learning that this isn’t
really the case.
The out of sight out, of mind is killing ocean
creatures and endangering our own health.
It turns out nowhere is safe from pollution.
Not even the deepest part of the ocean.
We can’t do DNews episodes without our sponsors.
Thanks to Graze for sponsoring this episode.
Graze makes snacking exciting by combining
wholesome ingredients with flavors we all
love, to create over 100 nutritionist-approved
snacks.
Go to graze.com and enter promo code DNEWS
to get a free, sampler box delivered to your
home or work.
So what actually lives down in the deepest
places on Earth?
We have a video all about that, here.
And do you have any other questions about oceans or pollution or science?
Let us know down below in the comments
and don't forget to like and subscribe for more DNews everyday.